[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend dans
lesésivelin Gabrielle et on commence
avec une sortie insolite je vous propose
ma-il d'un voyage dans le temps
direction l'époque médiévale pour ça
nous partons à Châteaufort où la foire
Saint-Simon revient pour une 37e édition
comme chaque année vous serez plonger
quelques siècles en arrière pour
retrouver l'ambiance et les ses coutumes
du Moyen-Âge l'occasion de rencontrer
stin ban sorcière et gentilhomme mais
aussi de tester les spécialités
culinaires et les activités artisanales
d'autrefis cette année la fauconnerie
est à l'honneur grâce à la troupe Les
Ailes de l'urga de quoi vivre le temps
d'un weekend comme au 13e siècle et
après avoir voyagé dans le temps
pourquoi ne pas voyager dans l'espace et
s'offrir explorer le ciel étoilé c'est
en tout cas un des objectifs de
l'événement national le jour de la nuit
c'est l'occasion unique d'explorer le
ciel étoilé tout en sensibilisant à la
pollution lumineuse notamment en
éteignant une partie de l'éclairage
public samedi soir la projection du
documentaire lumière sur la ville sera
proposée un film sur les enjeux et les
conséquences de la pollution lumineuse
des experts en astronomie seront
présents pour échanger la soirée se
déroule à la mairie de plaisir et dans
le parc du château vous pouvez consulter
le site qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran pour voir les communes qui
participent une sortie sport maintenant
avec de la Aquathlon l'Union Sportive de
viroflet organise dimanche 15 octobre la
la 2uxèe série Aquathlon des bertisette
alors Mathilde est-ce que vous savez ce
que c'est l'aquatelon alors non pas
vraiment mais à l'image j'ai vu une
personne qui nage et une personne qui
court dans la forêt donc c'est à peu
près ça le principe les participants
enchaînent une épreuve de natation dans
la piscine de la ville et une course à
pied dans la forêt l'année dernière une
centaine de sportifs avaient participé à
cet événement les organis ur en espère
le double cette année on écoute le
président de club du club de l'USM
virofflet on prend les enfants en
inscription à pr de 6 ans et
effectivement sur les adultes c'est 400
m de natation et 3 km de course à pied
on accepte effectivement toutes les
inscriptions licencié pas licencié jeune
moins jeune il y a également des courses
en relais parce qu'on peut participer à
deux effectivement un fait la natation
et l'autre faire la course à pied et
donc les inscriptions se font jusqu'à
dimanche sur place et le dossard peut
être retiré samedi après-midi à la
piscine et dimanche matin la piscine sur
place pour s'inscrire rendez-vous
également sur le site internet qui
s'affiche également en bas de votre
écran et on poursuit avec un événement
solidaire et inclusif oui pour la 20e
semaine du handicap Montini le
Bretonneux se mobilise au programme de
ce weekend convivial des animations et
et convivial et familial autour du
handicap mais pas que vendredi c'est une
session handicap recrutement qui est
organisé dimanche un grand jeu défi en
famille au programme curling escalade
raquette ou encore atelier sur l'essence
une exposition photo sur les athlètes an
disport sera également exposée
l'objectif mettre en avant le partage et
l'inclusivité alors justement le partage
et l'inclusivité font aussi partie des
enjeux de la nouvelle exposition du
musée lambiné le tactile tour pose ses
valises au musée Lambinet jusqu'au 15
octobre la particularité de cette
exposition itinérante permettent à des
personnes déficientes visuelles
d'accéder à des œuvres d'art
incontournables grâce à la modélisation
3D ce qui est intéressant avec cette
exposition c'est que tous les publics
sont invités à participer avec les mains
et les yeux ça permet aussi de faire
comprendre aux aidans et au grand public
ce que vivent les personnes avec un
handicap visuel l'exposition est
proposée par l'association Valentin aui
qui agit pour l'autonomie des aveugles
et des malvoyants et vous vouliez
terminer vos idées de sortie Gabriel
avec une autre sortie qui se passe à
versaill ce weekend oui un dernier
rendez-vous à noter la fête de l'automne
des antiires se tient jusqu'au 15
octobre à Versailles c'est LE
rendez-vous incontournable pour les
antiquitaires depuis 40 ans bien merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
idées de sortie